a Girl Scout project in Colorado shows
the strength of girl power five girls in
Aurora proposed a law to find drivers if
they're caught smoking with a child in
their car the Girl Scouts wrote the
ordinance and then presented it to the
mayor and city council the new law goes
in effect tomorrow Mary Peterson spoke
to them about this hands-on civic lesson
they are surely the youngest movers and
shakers in Aurora Colorado and
thirteen-year-old Julianna Martin knows
exactly how they did we just aren't the
type of people who it started as a Girl
Scout project create a city ordinance
then take it to the City Council their
proposed ordinance would make it illegal
for an adult to smoke in a car if there
is a child 18 or under in the same
vehicle our City Council heard the
concerns
Nancy Rogers aurora's senior assistant
city attorney helped them craft the
legal language I like that young girls
are interested in the legislative
process is this an empowering kind of
thing for girls do you think I think so
I think so there's not many women that
are in local government at the elected
level there was homework like
researching similar laws in other states
only eight states in Puerto Rico have
such measures in place there are no such
laws in Colorado good evening we are a
Girl Scout Troop six zero seven eight
nine
then came their night to advocate for
their law the health problems that can
affect minors are really bad asthma
attacks
if cotton pulled over you will face
consequences of both a one hundred and
fifty dollar fine which will be raised
by $50 for each offense and no less than
48 hours of community service when
Giuliana handed the ordinance to the
mayor she was very nervous normally what
we do is say please give these to the
city clerk but that was then this is now
now you've talked in front of the City
Council now you've learned what now I've
learned that it just takes a little bit
of courage and knowledge and
perseverance it was close some council
member
thought it was too much government
intervention the vote was a nail-biter a
5 5 tie until the mayor cast the
deciding vote
for Amelia Malcolm wasn't surprised that
they want we're all strong women and
we're a good group and we know each
other really well the new law takes
effect tomorrow the law is what's called
a secondary violation so if the police
stop you for something else and then see
that you're smoking in a car with a
child under 18 that's when you get cited
for doing this they each earned the
Silver Star the highest girl-scout honor
for their age group and while they
learned a good lesson we also taught the
grown-ups a lesson do you think people
listen enough to people of your age no I
feel like sometimes we're looking down
upon because we're just kids and we
don't know anything what we do and she
proved it so we better watch out next
time we just say just kids but I think
we accomplished more our age than babies
and they just might be right for CBS
this morning Barry Petersen Aurora
Colorado this isn't the last time we've
heard from these girls right writing not
to not to insult our parents but you
know they've done what do they have
Barry I'll buy any cookies from them any
time even to my phone number exactly